what's up everyone this is Anthony
papiano most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chain
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Erik Voorhees is the
founder and CEO of shape-shift and one
of the original bitcoiners in this
conversation we discussed the early days
of Bitcoin how he built and sold Satoshi
dice house shape-shift has evolved how
Eric thinks about kyc AML and other
regulations and what he is most excited
about as Bitcoin continues into the
future I really enjoyed this
conversation and I hope you do as well
skirts girl want to know who has the
best URL crypto comm that's right crypto
comm their crypto platform with one goal
mother in mass adoption that's why we're
all here we're trying to get crypto in
every wallet crypto comm is helping
people do that through buying earning
lending and card payment everything you
could want at crypto comm go help your
boy out tell them pump sent you download
the app or visit crypto comm pumps got
you always everyone to get into mining
and didn't know how don't worry your boy
pops gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an Xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right you purchase
it it shows up at your doorstep you pull
it out of the box you plug it in connect
to your Wi-Fi five minutes or less
you're mining Bitcoin all you have to do
is control it from the mobile app they
provide and then you receive
over-the-air updates that add new coins
and new features on a consistent basis
kind of like how Tesla does over-the-air
updates and updates the car software
just you're updating your coin mind
consumer mining made easy that's right
go to coin mine comm tell them tom
Sencha and thank me later as many of you
know crypto investors store their
digital assets on exchanges or in cold
storage for long-term safekeeping
however this strategy doesn't help them
grow their investment holdings or build
overall wealth with the new block by
interest account users can now securely
store their Bitcoin or
throughout block 5 and receive 6% annual
interest paid monthly and cryptocurrency
6% is an absurdly high rate it's the
best rate in the industry I highly
suggest you go check out block by.com
slash pop again that's block 5 comm
slash pop to sign up and start earning
crypto today you follow Bitcoin and
crypto
you've probably heard of eToro they're
the world's number one social trading
platform and I love it they've got more
than 10 million other traders that love
it too and guess what they just launched
the United States eToro offers access to
the world's most popular crypto
currencies including Bitcoin etherium
and others with the smartest trading
tools and the ability to connect with
the best traders around the world
there's no better place to build your
perfect portfolio if you're new to
Bitcoin and crypto you can test the
waters with their $100,000 virtual
trading feature but if you're more
experienced you can create custom
technical charts and use eToro social
fees to inform your trading decisions
they've got transparent fees and so you
never miss out they also have an
easy-to-use application available on an
iPhone Android or any web browser you
can get started today in just a few
clicks at be Toro comm again that's
eToro comm get VIP access to Bitcoin and
crypto markets today Anthony Pappalardo
is a partner at Morgan Creek digital all
pinnings expressed by pump or his guests
on this podcast are solely their
opinions and do not reflect the opinions
of Morgan Creek digital or Morgan Creek
Capital Management you should not treat
any opinion expressed by pomp as a
specific inducement to make a particular
investment or follow a particular
strategy but only as an expression of
his opinion this podcast is for
informational purposes only all right
guys bang-bang I'm here with Eric we are
in Laramie Wyoming of all places and we
don't have to too long but we want to
sit down real quick and talk a little
bit about his background how he
originally discovered Bitcoin what he's
doing at shape-shift and go from there
so they so much for taking the time to
do this yeah thanks for having me on the
show for sure let's start with that
background what would you do kind of
free Bitcoin crypto etc well immediately
pre Bitcoin I was in New Hampshire as
part of the Free State Project
what is that the Free State Project was
basically a crazy idea to get 20,000
radical libertarians to move to a small
jurisdiction like New Hampshire and make
some kind of material change since
libertarians seem to be a minority of
the population it made sense to actually
try to coalesce in one area and it was
actually from from a friend there that I
first learned about Bitcoin back in 2011
got it and and so as you wanted all
these people to move to the one area
what were some of the ideas in terms of
like what would be different than
visiting living somewhere else well
actually um Wyoming had also been
selected and it was kind of a close
second to New Hampshire but the Free
State Project is really like a long-term
thing it was it was already going for
like five or ten years before I got
involved and it's really kind of a
generational idea to move people to one
spot and just affect every level of the
society from politics all the way down
to just grassroots efforts and I thought
it was the best idea I had heard to
actually make a material difference in
the in the purpose of Liberty but when
Bitcoin came along it was just clear
that it had such a higher leverage value
and if we were successful with Bitcoin
it wouldn't be just one region but it
would be the whole world
it makes ton of sense what um what was
the first time that you ever heard of
Bitcoin or came across you remember what
that was yeah it was like May 8th of
2011 I just gotten back from a trip to
to the Caribbean and saw a Facebook post
about it from a friend in the Free State
Project
read an article as I got that sounds
stupid but I read another one another
one and then by the second or third
article I was totally hooked the the
idea of being able to move money for
free anywhere without anyone being able
to stop you was so obviously valuable
and interesting that I completely got
obsessed with it and instantly gave up
everything productive I was doing and
just totally fell down the rabbit hole
so what'd you do first first I was just
learning so much you know my background
is not in computer science at all I'm
not an engineer so there was a lot of
just learning you know what
these terms were everything about
cryptography I had no understanding of
any of that stuff and then also just
like really trying to use it and send it
around to people and I think I was one
of the first people who because I wasn't
an engineer my my value-add was in kind
of describing it to people and conveying
why I was useful from a monetary
perspective my background is in monetary
economics just by is a hobby of mine and
so I really latched onto it as like the
the way that the world can use money
without government's being involved got
it and so we don't have time to get into
a bit instant story and kind of some of
the earlier projects that you did if
people want to they can go read a Ben
MERS X buck Bitcoin billionaires that
covers on some of it but one of the
things that you did do that most people
listening to this either aren't aware of
or won't realize is Satoshi dice maybe
talked a little bit about just what that
was and kind of why you started it and
you know what happened yeah Satoshi dice
was a crazy phenomenon it started as
just a hobby side project while I was at
bitinstant
it was in April of 2012 and essentially
it was just an easy way to gamble your
bitcoins you could send bitcoins to a
certain address each address had
different odds and then a roll of the
dice would happen based on those odds
and you would either get more Bitcoin
back or you would lose your Bitcoin that
you sent in and the reason it was so
awesome was that it was provably fair so
you could actually prove after a bet
that the odds were correct and they were
what we said they were and because it
was Bitcoin it demonstrated the people
could send money anywhere in the world
instantly they didn't have to know who I
was they didn't have to trust Toshi dice
it just demonstrated the the power of
Bitcoin itself and the power of
cryptography to verify these kind of
rules for sure and so obviously that
went pretty well you ended up selling it
at one point and where how do you get
from Satoshi dice and bid incident to
shape-shift and what was kind of the
original idea there as to what you
wanted to build yeah so while I was at
bitinstant we had the Winklevoss
brothers invest in the company and
people can read that book that you
mentioned if they want to hear more
about that
story but let's just say it didn't end
very well and myself and another
business and guide named IRA we moved
down to Panama to co-found corner Pole
which was essentially just a Bitcoin
wallet and so I was down in Panama for a
year I decided I wanted to leave that
and move back to the US and I had an
idea for shape-shift sort of as I was
planning to move back it's a shape shift
are today Orly 2014 and so what was the
original idea that you started with and
then how's it evolved from there to you
know what what you're doing today so the
original idea was that I wanted to be
able to convert Bitcoin into another
coin
as easily as possible because they're
both digital assets it seemed that there
should be no friction between one and
the other and I saw that you know just
as Bitcoin was obviously valuable
because you could move money all over
the world these block chains were
valuable because you could do all sorts
of new financial products built on them
so I I thought there would be you know
thousands or millions of digital assets
probably multiple block chains and
people needed an easy way to move
between them so I built shape-shift
first just as a tool and it started
growing and growing and then you know as
the as when a theorem came out the
explosion of different assets really
took off the 20-17 bubble was absolutely
crazy and so did at some point between
you know little side project and and
today it became a real company and at
this point we're about 75 people and so
how is the business evolved like 2017
obviously was this crazy maniac time of
just everyone and their mom seemed to
want to buy a token and find it you know
that it was gonna be the next great
thing except her and if you were in any
sort of infrastructure I think there was
this almost like artificially high
influx of users and volume and then it
comes back down to more natural levels
how has that changed kind of your
business strategy in terms of maybe you
know what you were building pre mania
during the mania and then afterwards it
has there been a big shift or is it you
know still kind of do course of business
and and and going from there well
by the time that the 2017 bubble
happened I'd been through three bubbles
prior so the first one in 2011 one in
early 2013 and then the the big one in
late 2013 and so I felt how these how
this works that that you know Bitcoin
and these these things tend to go in
these cycles they tend to go up over
time but they're very volatile in the
short term they're real crazy on the
upside and real crazy on the downside
and as long as you can just handle both
and not lose your [ __ ] then it's a great
industry and so when the 2017 bubble
came along it wasn't a new phenomenon to
me but who each bubble has become more
and more intense than the last one
and every time they happen you get this
influx of new people almost all of whom
only care about getting rich quick and
when the bubble pops most of them go
away but not all of them and so you end
up getting just a growing group of core
people that get fascinated by the
technology so shape-shift really hasn't
changed you know post bubble what what
has changes that shape-shift implemented
koat seen accounts in late in mid or
late 2018 that was a fundamental change
to the whole business because before
that we didn't have any user accounts
whatsoever I'm I'm very vehemently
opposed to having to take personal
information from people we did it not
because we want to but because we were
forced or compelled to do it
and so that's been you know that was a
huge struggle for us as a company me
personally but that certainly changed
the business so let's talk about this a
little bit because I think that one
thing no one can take away from you is
that you're a very principled a trivet
right and you've been very clear about
but number eight the principles that you
have describe some of the issues that
you take with KY caml type stuff and the
collection of the personal information
for a lot of this infrastructure and
then maybe walk us through you know what
the decision-making process was to go
ahead and add some of it once you were
compelled to yeah so fundamentally I
think if you haven't heard anyone then
you deserve to be left alone and that's
really like the basis of my ethical
foundation so when it comes here I
so if you haven't hurt someone then then
you should be free that that's supposed
to be the foundation of what America is
built on and so in the context of
business
we don't need someone's name or address
or phone number or social security
number in order to trade crypto with
them we don't need that at all they
don't want to give it to us we don't
want to have it so so why do it and if
we take it then now we are endangering
that person because now their personal
information it's getting broadcast
across the Internet it's just not a good
thing to do on the other hand the
government wants financial institutions
to basically spy on people for them they
want the world to be they want companies
to basically be part of their
surveillance apparatus and they force
through law companies to do this early
on in shape-shifts history we felt
comfortable enough in the gray area it
wasn't clear whether we would be
considered a financial institution and
whether we had these kind of legal
requirements under US and international
laws after the 2017 bubble when we grew
quite large we started really looking
into this because the gray area was
getting less and less comfortable and we
navigated every contour of this stuff
that we could we spent literally
millions of dollars in multiple
jurisdictions trying to figure out
whether we would need to do this or in
what way and ultimately came to the
conclusion that if we didn't do it we we
would be probably thrown in a cage and
our lives would be over so faced with
that that's a pretty pretty shitty
position to be in and definitely it was
the most you know stressful
decision-making time and most difficult
challenge that I've had to deal with in
my life for sure and I guess as you kind
of look out past the KYC AML right
do you feel like the US companies are at
a disadvantage because of some of this
or is this something that you see across
the world people having to implement as
long as they're interacting at all with
legacy financial system and you know how
do you think about kind of jurisdiction
competition when it comes to the
regulatory environments yeah
so the u.s. is certainly not alone in
these requirements most of the world
requires them and what most people don't
realize is it's not just about where
your company is based or where you're
based it's about where your customers
are so if you want to block you know the
US all of Europe most of Asia you can
probably get away with a company that
doesn't do K Y Z or if you're still
small you might just be under the radar
and it's not gonna be an issue but to
build anything anything of size at scale
in which any of your customers are in
these jurisdictions you start running an
increasingly high risk and that was the
risk we weren't comfortable taking
anymore got it are there other
regulations that you feel like are
onerous or specifically kind of over the
top if you will and and not so much in
um you know I think one one part to
caveat in this conversation is you know
we've talked before and I think most
people that know you or others in the
industry would say a lot of these
beliefs are not rooted in like nefarious
activity right it's not like hey we
shouldn't have laws and regulations
because we want you know people to be
empowered to do bad things instead it is
much more around that individualistic
freedom and and right so from that
viewpoint making sure that that
viewpoint is clear like are there other
regulations that you say you know they
kind of fall in line with the KYC stuff
where they may not be necessary or they
may be a little bit more over the top
and owners yeah I'm pretty much not a
fan of it of any regulation yeah I mean
fundamentally you know when you go to
when you go to a restaurant they don't
kyc you you're permitted to pay
anonymously and eat and yet what if the
restaurant is serving a terrorist food
right you would be facilitating
terrorism by nourishing the terrorist
the same principle applies when it comes
to money the vast majority of your
customers are good people and haven't
done anything wrong there's not even a
suspicion or accusation of wrongdoing
and so to endanger them by taking their
personal information is is just purely
unethical in my opinion there are lots
of other regulations throughout the
natural industry I have my own issues
with the SEC for many reasons
I mean basically their rules prevent
only RIT or they prevent people who
aren't wealthy from investing in early
startups I think that's entirely
unethical I think things like what the
FDA does where they prevent life-saving
treatments from going to people if they
haven't gone through all their tests and
people literally die waiting for FDA
approval there's there's I could go on
and on with this stuff but it suffice to
say that I wish that America would start
moving back toward a the principle of
individual liberty that was founded on
and it's moved so far from that and I
don't see that changing in any
meaningful sense skirt school want to
know who has the best URL crypto comm
that's right
crypto comm there are crypto platform
with one goal mother mass adoption
that's why we're all here we're trying
to get crypto in every wallet crypto
comm is helping people do that through
buying earning lending and card payment
everything you could want at crypto comm
go help your boy out
tell them pomp sense you download the
app or visit crypto comm pumps got you
always everyone to get into mining and
didn't know how don't worry your boy
Pomp's gotcha everybody got some
electricity and Wi-Fi all you got to do
is go to coin mine comm you buy a coin
mine it's like an xbox or a PlayStation
that helps you turn your electricity
into Bitcoin that's right
you purchase it it shows up at your
doorstep you pull it out of the box you
plug it in connect to your Wi-Fi five
minutes or less you're mining Bitcoin
all you have to do is control it from
the mobile app they provide and then you
receive over-the-air updates that add
new coins and new features on a
consistent basis kind of like how Tesla
does over-the-air updates and updates
the car software just you're updating
your coin mind consumer mining made easy
that's right go to coin mine com tell
them Tom sent you and thank me later
one more word from our sponsor blocked
by their new interest account allows you
to securely deposit your Bitcoin or
Ethernet block by and receive six
percent annual interest paid monthly in
cryptocurrency this rate actually
compound so you receive a six point
- % e py which is very attractive given
the alternatives so you can actually
take your Bitcoin you can deposit it
with block Phi and get paid an interest
rate of 6% in return go check out block
5 comm / pop again block 5 comm / pop to
sign up and start earning interest on
your crypto today let's kind of go a
little bit more internal to the United
States you live in Denver I believe
right and most of people that we've had
on the podcast live in New York San
Francisco LA some are international but
we haven't really talked to folks in you
know kind of the mountain time zone if
you will talk a little bit about you
know why I choose to live in Denver kind
of what that ecosystem looks like crypto
and then just technology more generally
yeah well I I grew up in Colorado I grew
up in the mountains so I've always loved
Colorado generally and so when I moved
back here it was really just a lifestyle
preference I've lived in New York I've
lived in Dubai
I've lived down in Panama but the
mountains and the Sun and just the
beautiful land is something that I love
so Denver has been an amazing city it's
it's definitely not a financial hub but
it's a tech hub at this point and so
it's it's plenty large for us to hire
anyone we need to hire and you know
great food and beautiful place so my I
just love living there and I can fly
anywhere I need to pretty quickly so it
doesn't get better than that for sure
moving back to the crypto space what uh
what other areas are you personally
interested in right so outside of the
regulation like what do you the areas
you think are really important right now
that people should be paying attention
to
it may even serve as you know large
inflection points for for growth or
adoption so the the thing that most
people like on a macro level the thing
that is most exciting that people should
be really paying attention to is that
the conversation around monetary
attributes has hit not mainstream but I
would say mainstream politics and this
has largely been catalyzed by Libra
Bitcoin grow from this very small thing
and the people who are involved in it
care about the attributes of money and
what makes money good but that's not
something that the mainstream public has
cared about the word fiat was
ever used in normal discourse before
Bitcoin came out and through Bitcoin and
the crypto industry and especially
through Libra now politicians and
economists are taught are saying the
word Fiat they're talking about the
attributes of money they're getting
worried that someone like Facebook is
coming out with a currency because it
could compete with the dollar and harm
monetary policy that theme is amazing
that's like what we fantasized about you
know nine years ago and so it's that
that trend won't stop you know as a
crypto keeps growing as the fiat
financial system falls apart into the
next recession these things are going to
be hot topics of debate I think Bitcoin
will be villainized by economists libro
will be villainized by economists and
the politicians who basically want to
perpetuate the fiat banking system but
that that theme is just really
fascinating and is the thing that really
gets me excited every day I wake up you
get me excited just talking about it
what's kind of your view if we look out
you know 10 20 years what what is
actually possible is it a bitcoins the
global reserve currency is it Bitcoin is
a digital gold in everyone's portfolio
like what's kind of the new dream right
I think a lot of the stuff is happening
now was the dream of eight nine ten
years ago just because it seems so
improbable but high impact if that
happened what do you see now as you know
some of those milestones ten twenty
years from now so ten or twenty years
from now I think fiat currencies will be
mostly gone ten might be ambitious but I
think 20 years is probable and the
reason is that as Bitcoin takes over
people will tend not to save their money
in assets that are debatable
so dollar and any fiat currency is
highly debatable they are debased as a
matter of course in policy and people
just will at the margins tend to avoid
those things and hold their value in
something like Bitcoin so I think this
will be incredible because it will
restrain the ability of governments to
spend money they won't be able to
inflate currency anymore means
governments both to shrink I think
you will have some kind of you know
borderless global currency like Bitcoin
that everyone around the world will use
there won't be this idea of like the
currency you use is based on where you
live you know in the same way that the
internet has taken down all these
borders and people just talk to each
other anywhere in the world Bitcoin and
blockchain technology have done that for
money so people can now move value
anywhere in the world without these kind
of borders and arbitrary restrictions so
I honestly see it taking over the entire
financial system and I see the place of
the crypto industry as basically
building the alternative system to the
fiat and banking system it is definitely
looking like we're headed that way the
kind of competitors in the arena if you
will right now there's the fiat system
that we we've seen there's Bitcoin which
is this decentralized currency then
you've got what I'll call like the
corporate coins right so this is
everything from the Facebook's but also
the JP Morgan's the Wells Fargo's that
you know they're back and owned by $1
etc and then there's this last category
which is the Central Bank digital
currencies maybe you know what are your
thoughts there in terms of is that just
a perpetuation of the existing fiat
system is there some innovation there
that actually may save the central bank
systems like what do you think about
that yeah we had the same the same
discussion you know back in 2011 like
won't governments just create their own
digital currencies and the truth which
we you know said back then as well was
that Fiat already is a digital currency
so the US dollar is the world's largest
digital currency today all fiat
currencies are digital currencies and
the fact that there are a few bearer
instruments that are physical cash
doesn't mean that the fundamental
currency isn't digital so the question
of like will Google government's make
new new digital currencies that are fiha
yeah they'll probably try because they
think that will change things but they
will keep control over the system
they'll never relinquish control over
their new digital dollar and they will
always maintain the ability to inflate
it
so in what sense that's is that any
different than $10 today if a government
ever came out with a digital currency
that they could not control and that
they could not debase that could
actually seriously be a competitor to a
Bitcoin but no government will ever do
that yeah I tend to agree that that's
probably right before I wrap up I do
rapid-fire questions what do you think
is the most important company in Bitcoin
or crypto other than shape-shift we're
definitely not the most important
company in crypto I think I think you
gotta say either by an answer coinbase
due to the effect that they've had the
ability of finance to move into all
these different verticals and seemingly
execute very well over and over again
has to be admired and coinbase
I think more than any other company has
brought people into cryptocurrency so
for all their faults I continue to be a
big fan of coinbase
I hope to someday I'll compete them and
like you know destroy them but I also
think they're an incredibly important
company and deserve some admiration for
that there's nothing like admiring the
person that you're trying to destroy I
love that all right we were to talk
about the regulation stuff so I'll skip
that question what's the most important
book you've ever read most important
book I've ever read is probably what has
government done to our money by rothbard
very short you can read it in afternoon
but it it demonstrates sort of the
perversion of what money used to be you
know pre a hundred years ago to what it
is now in this full efya world and it it
just so cohesively demonstrates the the
moral failings of that process it was
something I read before Bitcoin and it
was something that really that got me
really interested in gold and that
really opened my mind so that it was
ready for Bitcoin when it happened but
that was absolutely a life-changing book
it's it's one that often gets
recommended on the podcast so people
will definitely should check it out
aliens what uh I usually end the podcast
you kid you get asked me a question but
we talked a Lian's first believer
non-believer
are you a going area 51 I'm not going to
area 51
obviously aliens exists
like it's just obvious who knows what
they look like they almost certainly
don't look like people but they
definitely are out there and and
probably gazillions and trillions of
different kinds of aliens so I would
love to meet one one day or just you
know know that they were on Mars or on
the moon or something weird but yeah
they're definitely out there most people
who come on that's their take it's just
mathematic probability is just math yeah
it's just that there has to be other
living life but or I guess other life
but the one thing is it doesn't have to
look like a little slimy green you know
man that we see in movies right it could
be a whole bunch of other different
things all right it's have ended what
one question do you have for me so my
question for you is when the financial
system starts falling apart Bitcoin will
be vilified to the extreme
it'll be attached to the D stability of
the government people who support it
will be called unpatriotic all that kind
of nonsense what what is your best
refutation of that human entrelac that
will happen so I'm gonna go a contrarian
on you a little bit in the sense that I
actually don't think that's gonna happen
and the reason is and maybe this is a
pipe dream or too optimistic on my
standpoint but you know we've been
successful in getting public pensions
exposure to Bitcoin there's now Wall
Street banks and financial institutions
that are starting to get access and so
it's a question of how much penetration
into the like quote unquote you know the
elites or the incumbents can we get
before that happens if there's deep
penetration I don't think they're gonna
be able to really deliver because you're
gonna basically vilifying yourself right
to some degree if there is not deep
penetration I agree that that could
happen and to answer your question in
that sense I think it's something where
the as information and and the Internet
makes that information more transparent
I think it becomes pretty obvious like
don't watch how people are saying just
watch what they're doing with their
money right you know in kind of
why is somebody saying something one of
my partners always says you know never
ask an incumbent about disruption right
because they they have very specific
views and so I would like to think and
again maybe too optimistic but it will
be easy to see why certain people are
railing against it it's because they're
the ones who have the most to lose but
you know I think we're gonna have to get
to that point to see really what happens
yeah I've certainly been happy that the
US has been much more tolerant of
Bitcoin than many of us feared back in
the early days so as long as that
process can continue and if thinking up
mainstream enough and if the tentacles
of this technology really gets you know
wrapped around the financial system in a
good way to where lots of powerful and
important people have already decided
it's worthwhile and and important
that'll be like an inoculation against
that kind of vilification I completely
agree listen I appreciate you you take
the time to do this it's been super fun
and you're building a great business so
we'll have to do it again in the future
to get some updates yeah thanks pump
things revenue young hey everyone
pop here if you like this episode of off
the chain and want to help us take
crypto to the top of the Apple Spotify
and other podcast charts please do us a
favor and rate review and subscribe to
review simply go to the off-the-chain
homepage scroll down until you see the
five blank stars taking 15 seconds to
fill those stars in and leave a quick
review goes a long way in helping us
take the entire crypto ecosystem to the
top of the charts I appreciate you
listening and see you next time I'm off
the chain
you